[Music]
6 43 here on a wednesday morning time
now for our mornings with metro segment
and today we're joined by assistant
sheriff laz chavez to answer your
questions and our questions this morning
how are you doing sir good to see you
very good thanks for coming in thank you
let's start talking about something that
we've been seeing recently it's not
necessarily a new issue but it certainly
got a lot more attention on social media
recently street racing drifting around
the valley
what kind of reports are you seeing
around town what's being done to try and
stop these things from taking place yeah
well what we've seen is it is it's a bit
of a national trend now too but we're
mostly focused on the northeast side of
the valley and over on the northwest
side of the valley these these reckless
drivers they take over intersections
they drive around circles they videotape
each other it's a dangerous uh element
of the for the general public so we're
responding out there as quick as we can
and we're working with community
partners
we try to get video of people doing this
and help identify some of these drivers
and these stunt drivers i remember at
the beginning of the pandemic we had
covered this a lot more because there
were fewer people on the streets and so
there was a lot of more folks were
taking advantage of that by drifting
around and and so forth
how quickly can you get out there i mean
it's not like those folks are taking
part are going to say hey rather we're
drifting out in near nellis uh how
quickly can you get out there and how
much of an emphasis is it well you'd be
surprised a lot of times this does go
out on social media so we try and stay
ahead of that we can get our helicopter
out there very quickly
and we work closely with community we
get a lot of phone calls so we respond
as fast as we can
we work with uh with surveillance video
a lot of times and we were able to
apprehend a few suspects that were out
there doing this stuff okay well keep an
eye on that let's switch gears to the
coronavirus and sadly
another sad situation with metro two
more officers have died recently from
covid19 we've spoken with the sheriff
about this before and others with the
department what is the latest with
vaccinations and cases within metro
police yeah that is sad and and tragic
and our prayers go out to the family uh
for their loss but for metro about 56
percent of our employees now have gotten
the first shot we're moving in the right
direction it's not quite where we want
to be uh we're following the governor's
uh mandate uh officers are wearing masks
and we're providing uh lots of
opportunity for them to get their
vaccine and even doing some pop-ups at
some of the police stations i know in
the beginning there was i don't know if
it was hesitancy but there was you know
there are union rules about mandating
vaccines for staff uh how is the
department and some of the brass trying
to not necessarily get around that but
try and make sure that everyone stays
safe while still making sure you follow
the the rules of the the contract well
that that is that is a hurdle that we're
dealing with we're trying to work with
the unions and uh and accommodate our
employees we we do provide as much as we
can uh to them and information we're on
this almost weekly try and encourage our
employees civilians and our commissioned
officers to to get the vaccine okay
well with vaccine mandates in place uh
across up and down the strip at some of
our large venues one of the concerns
that seems to be coming up is fake
vaccine cards what can you do what can
investigators do to make sure that when
folks are trying to get in they really
haven't vaccinated that's gonna be a big
issue moving forward along the strip too
of course yeah and and it's really
difficult at this point it's so early on
we're looking at our other law
enforcement agencies across the country
they're dealing with this we actually
haven't received very many calls at all
about this uh it's it's difficult you
know what do you do to verify these
cards do you call the hospitals to
verify the shots or not so we're asking
folks please be cautious of that if you
falsify a document you could be looking
at some different charges there too it's
not like if you're going to a legion
stadium to watch a raiders game you have
a fake vaccine card that you can just
call someone like there's that's that's
an instant kind of decision that has to
be made whether it's it's good or not
right right exactly exactly and in the
stadiums and that events are requiring
shots but that's certainly private
property they can make those decisions
on their own and we will do everything
we can as this moves on to try to figure
out how's the best approach for that it
is a gargantuan task for metro for
everybody else assistant sheriff chavez
thank you for joining us this morning we
really appreciate answering our
questions if you have a question for
metro police you can as always submit it
on 8newsnow.com we love hearing from you
as well find out if your question is
answered every wednesday during mornings
with metro 6